dalmat ravageur principal la pyrale une
catastrophe si fou combat avec son pire
ennemi
un prédateur qu'on va lâcher par la voie
des dix ans avec un groupe
alors ici on est dans un champ de maïs
qui se trouvaient à st pauli quand je
suis à gries fusion alors c'est la plus
grande ferme bio canado l'un des plus
grands la pirogue m'inspire papillon
dont la chenille s'attaque à toutes les
parties du plan puis sont
particulièrement problématiques dans le
bio le ce qu'on peut pas utiliser
d'insecticides
on va leur envoyer un prédateur après la
terre naturelle il s'appelle le
trichogramme habituellement lâché
manuellement dans les champs sur des
cartons comme celui ci sur laquelle il a
eu deux très grandes décoller alors
boutin beaucoup de travail beaucoup
d'argent nous avec un drone on voit
simplement lâché les trichogrammes
eleana verne du lot
alors la bête et dc ne s'est pas un tout
petit drone s'est scellée d'envergure de
problèmes effectivement pourquoi 50 60
cm de haut oui oui sur deux pattes à la
star mécanisme relativement simple de
distribution qui est branché sur le
pilote automatique et puis de les voir
voilà champ des points précis c'est
assez subtil le garder l'oeil van looy
et c'est très bien mais pas de vente
alors on va voir la flume que ça fait un
peu cassée il va faire un patin en pour
angers on va recourir très très loin
aujourd'hui
alors je me rends tranquillement au
touchant au dessus de la jonte dans le
milieu de la zone ou enfer l'activité je
le mets en mode automatique maintenant
il ya un petit peu de vent ont pu voir
ici redescendre à 10 mètres pour faire
son rot son activité de l'ag on les voit
d'associer la dose pour ce point l'oeil
50 dose comme cela par acteurs emprunt
ce qu'est ce qui va se passer à partir
du 6 mai alors dans les prochains dix
ans les trucs iron vont émerger il va
aller prendre l'oseille dans la spirale
à l'origine la pyrale juste dans la
piraterie pyrale le trio g voteront dans
la nature pion du rapport à un problème
de surpopulation des micro guêpe leur
confiance dans un avenir rapproché on va
pouvoir étendre comme seul le recours à
la lutte biologique à ces ravageurs h
convaincu pour moi c'est juste une
question de temps
[Musique]